New York has just become
the sixth state in the country
to legalize human composting
what is human composting it's exactly
what it sounds like human composting is
when you die they put you in a box they
put some plants and straw
and wood around you and they leave you
in that box for 30 days until you turn
to soil and then they pour you on the
ground
New York Governor Kathy Hogle
has added natural organic reduction
to Cremation and entombment as an
acceptable burial method
the new law defines the practice as the
quote contained accelerated conversion
of human remains to soil
in a structure room or other space in
which decomposition can occur now a
question I ask you is
is this wrong
I think most of us think this is wrong
oh it's I I imagine that the majority of
people listening to this show right now
would say yeah there's something kind of
wrong about this some people might say
no there isn't anything wrong but most
people have a gut feeling at least
there's something wrong about this and
then the second question
why is it wrong
that's the harder question
most people
especially the kind of people who accept
many of our culture's premises
that we should just follow our
unfettered reason and that people should
have the right to do whatever they want
to do consenting adults should have the
right to do whatever they want to do we
own our own bodies we're individuals it
is important to maximize our individual
autonomy people who believe these
premises which are not just the premises
of the crazy left they're the premises
of pretty much everybody after the
enlightenment in Liberal modernity even
many people who call themselves
conservative if you follow those
premises and that kind of logical
progression it's very difficult to
explain why it's wrong to turn Grandma
into a plot of dirt okay and then grow
your tomatoes out of you know dear Aunt
Sally
but it is wrong nevertheless
and it's it's wrong because all those
premises that we get out of liberal
modernity are are wrong too
it's wrong because
human beings have dignity
okay we are not
we are not the same thing as all the
other animals
we're not the same thing as plants we're
not the same thing as bugs we're
different we're human beings
we are made in the image and likeness of
God and that is why
we have a responsibility to show some
respect
for dead bodies
that is why there are laws throughout
the Civilized World against the
desecration of bodies what does that
mean to desecrate
it's recognizing that there is an aspect
of the body as being part of your
human self that is sacred
where you shouldn't desecrate that body
but what you'll hear from the libs and
the squishes is they'll say well you
know you're entitled to all your
religious mumbo-jumbo whatever but you
can't force that on us we're a secular
society well I guess we are I guess we
are if we're now at the point where the
way that we treat dear old grandma who
loved us all our lives is the moment she
dies to throw her into The Gardens of
the pigs can eat her and and tomatoes
can grow out of her then then I guess we
are a secular society but we shouldn't
be we didn't we didn't start out as a
secular society it's not what the
founding fathers set up it's not what
the framers set up it's not what we were
until five minutes ago
but now we may have become that there's
this really really good book that is
coming out soon by a writer named
Matthew petrusic who it's being
published by word on fire and it's a
book about evangelization and ideology
and I just did a blurb for it so I got
an advanced copy of this book but it's
really great I encourage you to
pre-order it and get the book because it
does a great job of explaining how
political issues the political debates
that we have
are just one tiny little fraction of the
broader debates that we
the the conclusions of which we are
simply assuming
I'll bring this down to earth a little
bit when we're debating a policy like
whether or not to throw Graham in the
garden
that political debate is assuming
a lot of conclusions about applied
morality
and that's kind of the next circle out
applied morality which is assuming a lot
of conclusions about morality
generally
which is assuming a lot of conclusions
about
epistemology about how we can know any
epistemologies is how we know anything
at all it's the study of knowledge how
do we know things how do we know that
certain things are true and certain
things are false certain things are good
and certain things are bad
then
you go out a circle further well that
assumes a lot of things about
anthropology we talk about anthropology
a lot when it comes to the transgender
debate what does it mean to be a human
being what is human nature can a boy
become a girl can a girl become a boy
these are going to be just assumed in a
lot of our political debates when you
move out from anthropology you get to
ontology the the question of being what
it what it means to be what it means to
exist and when you have
those questions those questions are
assuming conclusions from theology
what what is the fundamental
reality what is reality
within which all of those other
questions would exist
we unfortunately just go into these
debates blindly in many ways
and the worst part is everyone goes
blind we're not going to have you know
extremely high level scholarly debates
over every single question that comes
before the Congress
problem is though we are assuming all
sorts of conclusions about all those
really high level questions
we used to assume them with the
Prejudice of tradition with the
Prejudice of
civilization with the Prejudice of
Christianity these days we are assuming
those premises
with the prejudices of liberalism of
leftism of atheism and when you just
take all there is no God that's one
premise we're assuming or if there is a
God we can't really know anything about
him being is merely physical human
beings are just a bag of chemicals the
only way we know anything is through the
microsope and the scientific method
morality is just whatever the people
want at any given time or whatever makes
me feel good if it feels good do it and
so if grandma wants to get thrown into
the garden that's fine or if we want to
throw in the garden that's fine too well
yeah I see how you could arrive at that
stupid conclusion but you've arrived at
it by assuming all sorts of conclusions
about about higher level thinking that
are simply not true okay and the the the
prejudices has become wrote for us
because the libs
conquered the culture and it's going to
take a lot to dig ourselves out of that
but the I think the first thing we have
to do is dig Grandma out of the garden
okay and dig her out of the tomato plant
we shouldn't that is we know that is
wrong we have a wisdom of repugnance to
borrow a word from Leon Cass we know we
shouldn't do that there is nothing wrong
or irrational or stupid or uneducated
about using our law to say no you don't
get to do that
no you should you should be buried I I'm
actually against cremation as well I
know a lot of people opt for it I think
cremation makes a mockery of of
a notion that animated our culture for a
very long time which is the resurrection
of the body this is a central uh concept
of Christianity yeah yeah and and it
matters even beyond what will happen to
us in the Hereafter or at the second
coming or the final judgment because it
it gets down to the question of what is
the relationship between the soul and
the body who what am I really if the
body doesn't mean anything then
transgenderism is A-Okay right because
my true self is just my soul my body is
incidental to that if I want to chop it
up even if a little kid wants to chop it
up no big deal but I don't think that's
true I think the body does matter so
much so that I'm reminded of the words
of tertullian who said that
the Salvation is the very hinge or
rather the flesh is the very hinge of
Salvation okay that our bodies and what
we do with our bodies when we do in time
and space really do matter so we should
not just become mulch okay you are more
than mulch
[Music]
[Music]